so one of the things I have been trying
to communicate to you guys is that the
world manifests itself through a pattern
a basic pattern that I've traced in
different ways talking about the
mountain in Genesis heaven and earth the
kind of the pattern that you'll also
find in st. Gregory of nYSSA's life of
Moses that you'll find as well in my
brother's book matures book the language
of creation and different aspects of
reality tend to manifest different parts
of that pattern but there are some
things which manifest the whole pattern
in a very concise way and this is very
much the case in many of the things that
are talked about or the things that are
taught to us by Christ and so today what
we're going to do is we're going to look
at the Lord's Prayer itself the way that
Christ taught us to pray and I will try
to show you that the Lord's Prayer just
like the mountain of Moses just like the
Garden of Eden follows the same pattern
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
now in scriptures there are two versions
of the Lord's Prayer but we're going to
choose to talk about the Virgin in the
Gospel of st. Matthew which has the
longer version which is the one we
mostly know in the way that we pray in
churches in a way it doesn't really
matter because the version that's in st.
Luke has the same elements as in the
Gospel of st. Matthew it's just that in
the Gospel of Matthew there tends to be
a multiplication which can help us see
the pattern even more clearly but it's
still all there in the Gospel of Luke
and so the prayer starts with everybody
knows the prayer I hope that you know
the prayer the prayer starts our Father
who is in heaven of course when we talk
about heaven it's very important not to
understand it as the sky just as the sky
in Scripture it talks about the heaven
of heavens the notion that there is a
heaven above the heavens which contains
all the heavens and it really is the
first heaven in Scripture in Genesis in
Genesis there's all right there is the
first heaven when it says God created
heaven and earth and then there's a
lower heaven the firmament which is akin
to heaven but is lower let's say on the
ontological hierarchy the heaven in
Scripture is really the invisible fully
invisible place the the place of
principality you would say and you can
see that the relationship between the
father and heaven it has to do with the
idea of the source you know the source
the father is the source of the family
and the sense that he sends the seed and
the seed is that which creates the the
family with his wife and so to the
father sends his seed which in this case
is the word and the word comes down and
is that which creates the entire world
and so this relationship between father
in heaven is of course completely
coherent in the sense that you as a
child also you know it's a it's very
intuitive your father is above you when
you're a child and you you look up and
you see your father
and so the notion that you would look up
and that the things which are above you
you know the heaven itself would be akin
to the Father also like I said the fact
that that your identity comes down from
your father he names you he gives you a
a he gives you your first structure he
gives you he is your first first
authority and so in that sense God as
our Father because we all originate from
him is a completely normal analogy until
we say our Father who is in heaven
hallowed be your name and the name is
related of course to the idea of God
himself the the name is that which
points to something and so we glorify
God's name we glorify the manner by
which he manifests himself and the name
of God is also in a way the logos
himself that is when God names himself
when he says I am the one who is we can
understand that as the Yahweh in the
scripture we can understand it as the
the divine logos the manifestation of
God so God manifests himself firstly by
his name by showing us who he is before
he actually ontologically before he
creates things we first the highest
aspect of God you could say something
like is his name because it is the the
first thing that can help you look up
and understand that there's something
about it so we hallow we glorify we lift
up we we want to to acknowledge how high
his name is how high the this encounter
we have with God how high it is we place
it above in the heavens and we put it
together with God so you have the Father
heaven and the name all above okay so
you're gonna have to keep that spatial
symbolism in mind that's really the key
to so much to so much symbolism in order
to understand how it lays itself out so
you have the Father you have the heaven
you have the name and then it says your
kingdom come and so what exactly is a
kingdom a way to understand the kingdom
is to understand the kingdom as the
scope of the reign of a king
so all that which is under the rule of
the king is his kingdom and so you can
understand
imagine the king above everything and
then whatever it is that the king rules
over his land his people the identity of
his people all of these things imagine
it like a mountain now again as a
pyramid or as a mountain all of these
things are the kingdom of God and so we
first lift up right we lift up God the
Father heaven and then we say we want
your kingdom to come we want the world
to be under your rule we want the world
to manifest in an orderly manner
the fact that it is connected to you to
the father to heaven and to the name
okay keep also the name in mind because
that's also part if we want to
understand how the Lord's Prayer is
actually a cosmic image which although
we up we ultimately it applies to God it
also shows us the pattern of reality
because you can also understand the
kingdom of something as whatever it is
that it names and so I'm going to use
the same example I use all the time you
can imagine a cup and so you can imagine
that the cup has a kingdom okay so the
cup the cup nests of the cup is up there
and whatever falls under its toughness
whatever specific examples of cups
whatever varieties of cups whatever you
know all the multiplicity which is
contained in the cup is the kingdom of
the cup okay but now we're talking about
all of reality and so we are talking
about all of reality as being this
kingdom which manifests the name the
identity the the heaven which is above
okay and so then it goes on to say you
will be done on earth as it is in heaven
so now we have the coming about of the
first lower term we have now on earth as
it is in heaven
and so we've shown the entire pattern
already we've already
kind of stretch the entire world out we
say we start with heaven we have heaven
above there the father the name and then
we have the kingdom of the Father which
manifests him itself we have the will of
the Father because the will and the
kingdom is the same thing the the
capacity for your will to manifest
itself in the world is the the rule that
you have over the things around you and
so whatever influence you're capable of
having on the world that is your rule
like you are a little King and say a
king of your house and you want your
rule to your will to be done in your
house so that it doesn't fall into chaos
it doesn't fall into disorder that it
doesn't fall into transgression you know
that you don't have everything upside
down and all the clothes on the ground
and all of this and so you want your
will to be done in your house and now
ultimately cosmically we want God's will
to be done on heaven in earth as it is
in heaven
and this this this idea of on earth as
it is in heaven
this is the point I often talk about the
world as this mountain you can imagine
that the point as the mountain heaven
above the mountain and then the point
the place where heaven and earth meet
that is what this is talking about on
earth as it is in heaven as a reflection
of that which is above that which is
below becomes an image of that which is
above and we see that in many places in
scriptures when it talks about how God
is hidden in all of creation and in the
tradition of the church this whole idea
of the Logie this this notion in st.
Maximus the Confessor that I've talked
about so many times that everything in
the world has an essence has something
which is above it's phenomena
necessarily as the cup again you know
the the the compass of the cup is not
contained in the physical cups you can't
get to physical Cup just by the to to
the essence of a cup just by the
physical cups it's it kind of jumps up
above all the multiplicity and so you
know that is a it's a visible but the
idea of the logos is that even behind
that there's an essence which is
unknowable to a certain extent that you
can't totally define
it's not its definition it's kind of
behind the definition that which gives
birth to the definition and that is all
of these things are how God reflects
himself in the world and so your will
your essence your energies when we talk
about energies in the Orthodox Church we
are talking about God's will until we
say your will your energies your your
will be done on earth as it is in heaven
and the world becomes the body of God in
a way the world becomes the kingdom of
God all of these expressions that you
find in Scripture that is what it is
talking about here so you already have
this this thing stretched out and so now
it talks about give us this day our
daily bread and what's interesting about
the this phrase is that there are many
ways that it's been translated because
the word that's used for daily is
something like trans you know something
like trans essential bread or something
like that some people call trans
substantial bread or trans essential
bread and this notion that the bread
it's a word that is it's almost like a
neologism but no matter how you
understand it you can end up understand
it as the bread which comes down from
heaven you have to understand it as the
manna that's in the Old Testament which
God sends down from heaven and is that
which feeds us and the importance of
bread is the bread is very important as
well because bread is exactly this
connection between heaven and earth
that's what bread is bread is seeds it's
it's a seed that you mix with water and
then you have bread just like the entire
cosmos is word of the word of God which
comes down on the primordial ocean of
creation and poles reality out of it
bread becomes an image of this actual
meeting and so this call for for bread
is a call again for the rule for the
kingdom but in a manner which shows us
that we are dependent on this that we
live through this that we we need it to
to exist with
this bread which comes from heaven we
cannot exist we will die right and so it
becomes our daily bread or it becomes
our transics essential bread this that
this idea of a something which brings us
higher in that sense and so it all fits
into this this nice pattern you know of
the world and so coming down from heaven
once again you have the name you have
the will you have the kingdom and you
also have this bread which these the
seeds that come down and connect with
the water of the world and you mix it
together you cook it and you've got that
which sustains us okay the meeting of
heaven and earth that's what bread is
all the time and then it goes on to say
and lead us not oak sorry then there is
forgive us our trespasses as we forgive
those who trespass against us another
translation forgive us our debtors as we
forgive those who are indebted to us
both of those are the same thing and now
you can understand it as the word
trespass is a good word because you can
understand it now imagine now the
mountain again or I've talked about the
mountain often can be represented as a
path so you have this path which leads
you up to the point where heaven and
earth meet and then you have the
trespasses you have the the things you
do you have the the aspects of yourself
which step off the path which go down
the path or which are not you know don't
hit the mark
you know don't hit the center kind of
don't totally manifest the will of God
in the worlds or those seeds that will
that Kingdom there are ways that we act
in which we step aside from that so you
can imagine as the bottom of the
mountain now so you have heaven you have
earth you have this mountain in the
middle of the kingdom and then you have
the place where we kind of are down at
the bottom of the mountain we're
stepping off into the wilderness we are
stepping on thorns we are there's all
this imagery in scripture about the
trespass where we we miss out right and
so we ask God
- forgive us our trespasses so that we
can go back up so that we can
participate in the kingdom so that we
can eat the bread so that we can do his
will all of these things are all the
same in terms of with it what they're
talking about and we also say as we
forgive those who trespass against us
that's really important because now it's
showing us until now we've had the
horizontal move right you have all the
things coming down from heaven
we've had our response which is to ask
God to bring us up by forgiving us that
all the things we do that are stepping
aside from what we're supposed to be and
how was where we're supposed to look but
now they manifest on the horizontal
which is that this moving up is a coming
together as well and I've talked about
this all the time this notion that that
there's a there's a vertical move and a
horizontal move that is the communion of
the Saints the existence in love the
well-fitted 'no sin love is that which
manifests the kingdom of god and so for
the mountain to hold together there has
to be this thing coming down from above
which manifests the essence of the Wills
but there also has to be a coming
together at the base in order to stay
connected to the top and so we ask God
to forgive us and then we forgive those
around us so that we stay in communion
with those around us we are we love
those around us just as God loved us and
without that without us loving our
neighbor without us forgiving the
trespasses of others we cannot
participate in this upward movement
because the upward movement is the
coming together of the the lower parts
you know for a cup to exist it has to
glue coal together if you throw it on
the ground and it smashes into pieces
and it's not holding together you are no
longer manifesting the essence of the
cup you're no longer manifesting the
kingdom of the cup it has to come
together for the essence of the cup to
appear you know we see Christ talked
about that all the time he says or two
or three our guy
together in my name then I am in the
middle of you okay so in the name we in
the name we have it in this as well your
holy be your name the will of God when
we gather in the will of God in the name
of God then Christ is at our center
Christ becomes our head becomes the top
of us okay all of this is talking about
how reality lays itself out and then
finally we have the last part which is
really the lowest part and it talks
about you know lead us not into
temptation or lead us not into trial let
us not fall into trial different ways of
translating it in a way it doesn't
matter because it it's it's one step
lower so you have this idea of the
trespass and then you have the things
the dark things on the sides that are
that are calling us you know all these
dark principalities on the outside all
these these things that are pulling us
apart from each other that are tempting
us that are that are like a stumbling
stone that are a trial that are all
these things that are going to bring us
away from the name from the kingdom from
the from the will of God and is also
going to separate us from each other and
so we want God to not let us fall into
this outside darkness we want God to
keep us in the light where his will is
being done and where we are loving our
neighbors all of this is completely
coherent and finally and deliver us from
evil and that is of course the the final
you could call the upside down at the
edge you know the the devil himself who
is this separator who's the divider the
one who is the accuser all of these
images of evil are on the very fringe of
the world and are accusing you so that
you fall away so that you get pulled
away from the kingdom of heaven from the
kingdom of God and so you can see how
the prayer itself is a repetition of the
pattern of creation and the fall in
Genesis it is a repetition of almost all
the stories in scripture it
the same pattern from starting from
above showing us the world in between
and how the world falls apart on the
edge and what we need to do in order to
stay connected to each other and also
stay connected to God but like I said
this prayer obviously is ultimately
about our relationship with God in our
coexistence as the church and as the
body of Christ all these things but it
is also a pattern of reality every
identity every smaller identity also
participates in this pattern and so in
order using the cup but it's a good a
good way a good good example and it's an
easy one because I keep using the same
one use different example of the same
thing and so you have the the identity
of the cup which is up in heaven it is
invisible it is a it is an essence it is
beyond the multiplicity and it has a
name its name is the place where it
comes together in itself and you want in
order to be able to participate in cups
you need the kingdom of the cup to come
down on you know pieces like ceramic or
like paint or like whatever your cup is
made of you need the kingdom of the cup
to come down and manifest its will you
know on earth as it is in heaven if the
will if the will the identity of the cup
the name of the cup and the will of the
cup is not manifesting itself properly
in the world then you're gonna have a
cup with holes you're gonna have a cup
that you know that is a weird shape that
is hard to drink from whatever it is you
want the kingdom of the cup to manifest
itself fully in the world and then you
get to the you have to have some
flexibility towards the exceptions you
don't you can't be completely rigorous
in terms of the the essence of the cup
because the essence of the cup is too
high anyways and so there is no pure cup
in the world and so each cup will have
something which will not be perfect and
so you have to be forgiving as well you
have to be understanding you have to be
able to recognize the essence of the cup
and the multiplicity in a way you
forgive the little trespasses of the cup
you don't want to be too soon
or else you won't drink anything because
nothing actually manifests the full
essence of it and finally you don't want
the cup to be destroyed you don't want
the thing that's going to knock it off
the the table to break it on the ground
you don't want the person is going to
come in and steal the cups from your
house you don't want that to happen you
want the that you want the kingdom of
the cup to to participate appropriately
and so I'm afraid that some people might
think that I'm being somewhat
blasphemous when I'm using a cup as an
example but I think it's very important
to understand the manner in which
reality functions as a fractal pattern
when we talk about how the the glory of
God is hidden in creation that that
everything in the world manifest God
that's not an arbitrary thing it's not
an emotional thing it's not I feel like
God is manifesting himself in the world
it is an actual objective reality it's a
true thing which you can participate in
which you can see and which manifests
itself at lower levels everywhere in the
world pointing up towards the absolute
version of it which Christ reveals to us
in this prayer that he has given us and
so as as lent is you know moving on as
we are hopefully trying to spend more
time in prayer sometime fasting as well
for most of you watching this I imagine
as well and trying to refocus ourselves
we can remember as we pray the Lord's
Prayer it's good to pray it at least
everyday to remember how beautiful it is
how much it it not only brings us into
the presence of God that it ought not
only is the prayer that Christ gave us
the ultimate prayer in a way but it
isn't the ultimate prayer because it
also shows us the very structure of
creation and the very manner in which
God interacts with the world so I hope
this was helpful for you and everybody I
just want to thank you for your support
thank you for for all these people that
are helping me out you know I told you
that we're going to start a blog very
soon things are right
process right now people are writing
articles people are editing articles and
very soon my website is going to become
a platform for writing you're going to
see some people you've seen on my
channel before you can see JP you'll
probably see Alistair Roberts you will
see Nicolas Kotar as well and a whole
bunch of other people who I'm really
excited for you to discover
so everybody thanks again and I will see
you very soon